[Musique]
20 minutes il ne recherche pas la
performance bien sûr pour ces quatre
résidants de la maison de retraite les
seuls c'est le dernier atelier vélo
après trois mois d'exercice ces deux
vélos voir ça me plaît tout le temps et
tourne sans arrêt c'est sensationnel je
me suis dit il faut à tout prix faire du
sport alors voilà je suis là et je suis
devenu sportif ne pas me laisser aller
donc qui errent à booster intérieur qui
se développe et c'est vrai que quand on
veut faire quelque chose de bien on
force un petit peu les choses dix
résidents de cet établissement ont pu
bénéficier du programme cyclisme santé
de la fédération française de cyclisme
deux séances par semaine on a vu une
évolution au niveau du souffle et au
niveau du rythme de pédalage savoir
qu'en début de en début de cycle il y
avait une intensité qui était vraiment
modérer les résidents parcours est entre
2 et 4 km sur la séance et puis du coup
aujourd'hui c'était la dernière séance
le vélo c'est une activité où on est
porté c'est non traumatisant pour les
articulations donc pour les résidences
et c'est très sympa à pratiquer voilà il
n'y a aucune charge aucune résistance
imposés les ateliers vélos sont soutenus
par le département des yvelines une
première en france les ateliers durent
entre trois et six mois
c'est un pari mais junte à paris à la
fois osé mais d'autant plus utile dans
ces périodes on pourrait avoir tendance
à se replier sur soi donc l'objectif
c'est vraiment d'amener la salle de
sport nepad avec toutes les conditions
de sécurité technique et médical bien
entendu douze structures et 120
personnes âgées sont actuellement
concernés l'établissement guyancourt toi
envisage déjà de reproposer cette
activité